bonsoir et bienvenue à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mercredi
l'algérie en deuil al qaïda au maghreb a
revendiqué le double attentat d'hyères
qui a fait 72 morts selon la presse on a
appris que l'un des kamikazes était âgé
de 55 ans à chaque jour ses surprises
pour la visite du colonel kadhafi le
numéro un libyen critique les droits de
l'homme en france en évoquant le
traitement des immigrés pitoyable répond
bernard kouchner
la prison à perpétuité avec une période
de sûreté de 22 ans c'est la peine
requise contre yvan colonna devant la
cour d'assises spéciale de paris
le verdict est attendu demain dans la
soirée ce sera l'un des grands chantiers
du quinquennat nicolas sarkozy a lancé
la réforme de l'état qui vise à
redresser les finances publiques
une centaine de mesures ont été
présentées pour réorganiser les services
un divorce devant le notaire sans passer
devant un juge la mesure devrait entrer
en vigueur dans les mois qui viennent
elle reflète la banalisation toujours
croissante des séparations
enfin le pavé dans la mare du
prestigieux magazine américain times qui
titre sur la mort de la culture
française vieille rengaine ou constat
lucide c'est le débat de cette édition
d'abord donc l'incompréhension en
algérie au lendemain des deux attentats
suicide
toute la journée les familles et les
sauveteurs étaient à la recherche de
proches disparus sous les décombres le
dernier bilan donné par la presse je
vous le disais et de 72 morts et c'est
bien la mouvance al qaïda qui a
revendiqué cette double explosion sur
place sa masse ou là patrick desmulie
jour et nuit depuis hier les fouilles
n'ont pas cessé pour tenter de retrouver
des survivants six ont pu être dégagées
grièvement blessé au fil des heures
l'espoir des familles s'amenuisent au
siège de l'onu plusieurs victimes
restent introuvables
ces femmes cherchent une cousine disparu
ce rescapé revenu sur les lieux
il n'en revient toujours pas i gr
frapper au coeur c'était impensable
ces hauts murs de béton ces barbelés le
quartier abrite la plupart des expatriés
dont de nombreux français
tous sont employés
par de grandes entreprises qui ne lésine
pas sur leur sécurité
cette française et son époux en font
partie avec son mari et leurs trois
enfants
ils ont choisi de vivre dans une maison
aux allures de bon coeur dans un bunker
non mais dans une maison où il ya un
minimum de sécurité
il est vrai que je fais attention qui
sonne chez moi mes enfants ne vont pas
jouer dans le quartier ou dans la rue
seul on savait que qui avait une
éventualité de ce genre d'événement mais
aujourd'hui si la situation stagne nous
resterons ici
le couple ne se sent pas
particulièrement menacé mais le mari
cadre dans une grande entreprise
algérienne préfère rester discret on
s'est rapprochés effectivement de
l'ambassade de france assez claire de
façon à ce que si demain il y avait des
événements beaucoup plus lourds qui ne
sont pas du tout alors deux je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on serait proche de
l'exfiltration ci a eu lieu d'abord pour
l'heure aucun départ massif d'expatriés
en algérie est à l'ordre du jour bonsoir
samah soula vous êtes en direct à alger
quelles sont les informations concernant
l' enquête coûté 24 heures après les
attentats les autorités algériennes
donne peu d'informations sur l'état de
l'anc est ce que l'on sait c'est que ces
attentats ont été revendiqués par la
branche d'al qaïda au maghreb et qu'il
s'agit d'attentats kamikazes ce qui
frappe ici les algériens c'est qu'un de
ses kamikazes
est un homme âgé de 55 ans qui changent
du profil habituel des kamikazes plutôt
jeune et influençable merci sam a pour
ces précisions autre attentat ce matin à
beyrouth au liban c'est un général 4e
plus hauts dirigeants de l'armée
françois el hajj qui a été tué avec son
garde du corps par une voiture piégée à
la sortie de la ville un attentat
considéré comme une nouvelle tentative
de déstabilisation car l'officier était
un proche de michel suleiman commandant
en chef de l'armée et candidat favori à
la présidence
et puis on parlait récemment de
l'accalmie en irak et bien les attentats
n'ont pas disparu pour autant
33 morts aujourd'hui dont 28 dans la
ville d'amara une cité chiite au sud de
bagdad
on en vient tôt feuilleton il faut bien
l'appeler ainsi de la visite du colonel
kadhafi décidément hors norme
aujourd'hui le numéro un libyen toujours
accompagné de sa suite imposante s'est
promené en bateau-mouche sur la seine du
coup les pompes paris ont été fermée aux
piétons
il a aussi rencontré des associations de
femmes revu nicolas sarkozy mais le fait
marquant de ces dernières heures sont
ses propos critiques sur les droits de
l'homme en france
philippe rochot stéphane guillemot c'est
la deuxième visite à l'elysée du colonel
kadhafi depuis son arrivée en france
mais c'était la première fois qu'il
revoyait nicolas sarkozy après qu'il ait
démenti avoir abordé avec lui le
problème des droits de l'homme kadhafi
n'en semblait pas gêner mais pas de
caméras autorisés pendant son entretien
de 45 minutes avec nicolas sarkozy hier
soir à l'unesco devant les africains le
bouillant colonel en superstar avait mis
le doigt sur le problème de
l'immigration dans notre pays une
réponse à ce thème des droits de l'homme
en libye que ses interlocuteurs lui
renvoie au visage depuis son arrivée en
france
nous travaillons dans le bâtiment dans
la construction des routes et après cela
nous sommes envoyés dans les banlieues
et nos droits sont violés par les forces
de police
sa visite à l'assemblée nationale pousse
la gauche a dénoncé une mascarade
bernard kouchner doit une nouvelle fois
justifié sa position par les des droits
de l'homme ici c'est à dire des droits
de l'homme dans notre pays en europe
c'était assez pitoyable et nous le
condamnons
il y a les paroles et nous les
condamnons souvent mais il ya aussi
l'évolution depuis quelques années
passage rapide au pied de la tour eiffel
les ponts de la seine sont interdits aux
piétons car le colonel kadhafi fait une
promenade en bateau puis c'est la
rencontre avec les associations de
femmes africaines en majorité musulmane
au pavillon gabriel
se battre pour développer l'afrique va
pas quand même resté au tiers-monde
jusqu'à chez paquet d'années se battre
on s'est réveillé kadhafi ça va aller
mieux
oui de 20 fin de la visite officielle du
colonel kadhafi qui visitera le château
de versailles
mais il ne quittera la france que samedi
et alors que ce voyage se poursuit nous
sommes retournés à bengazi
c'est là en libye que travailler les
infirmières bulgares et le médecin
palestinien soupçonné à tort d'avoir
contaminé 438 enfant du virus du sida
aujourd'hui les infirmières vous le
savez ont été libérés elles sont
rentrées chez elles
les enfants eux sont toujours là ils
sont mises au ban de la société renault
bernard avec jouit relatif bengazi sur
les bords de la méditerranée
les infirmières bulgares et le médecin
palestinien sont rentrés chez eux les
enfants contaminés par le virus du sida
sont toujours là eux mais ils ont été
mis au banc dans leur propre pays
yahia est séropositif depuis neuf ans il
n'a pas encore développé la maladie
j'ai arrêté l'école à cause de ma
contamination je n'ai rien à faire du
matin au soir c'est toujours la même
chose
j'aimerais tant jouer avec les autres au
club comme avant les personne ne veut de
moi à bengazi une seule école accepte
les enfants contaminés en principe mais
yahia ne vient pas y étudie entre la
pression populaire et la honte de leur
famille les enfants malades comme la
soeur de saad n'y sont plus scolarisés
ma soeur est malade du sida les gens ne
veulent pas nous approcher ni elle ni
moi ni mes parents ils disent vous avez
un virus dangereux et nous on n'ose même
plus sortir dans la rue
au début dans cette école nous avons
voulu intégrer les enfants malades
ça a été une catastrophe les autres
parents ont retiré leurs enfants
l'exclusion en libye l'homo sida
n'existe même pas ici on ignore
complètement le sida merci à la france
de nous avoir son mais il nous faut
encore plus d aide à nous les victimes
pourtant la communauté internationale à
verser des centaines de millions d'euros
avant la libération des infirmières et
300 millions de plus promis depuis avec
la libye affirme avoir modernisé
l'hôpital de bengazi c'est parce qu'ils
étaient insalubres que les 438 enfants
ils ont été contaminées probablement par
des seringues usagées et des
transfusions sanguines ont sécurisé
voici le nouvel établissement la libye
le montre pour la première fois avec ses
équipements ultramodernes
l'union européenne considère que ce
laboratoire est l'un des plus modernes
de tout le continent africain mais en
libye pas plus qu'ailleurs on guéri du
sida sur les 438 enfants contaminés en
1998 56 ont déjà été vaincu par la
maladie
et pendant que nicolas sarkozy reçoit le
colonel kadhafi en france une image de
jacques chirac qui lui est en afrique en
mauritanie hier au sénégal aujourd'hui
l'afrique qui sera au coeur des
activités de la future fondation de l'ex
chef de l'état c'est ce qu'il a indiqué
ce soir des images signées frédéric
guiraud en france le procès d yvan
colonna touche à sa fin leur était ce
matin au réquisitoire et l'avocat
général n'a pas fait de détour
yvan colonna est l'homme qui a appuyé
sur la détente est tiré trois balles sur
le préfet erignac at il lancé d'emblée
il a demandé ensuite la peine la plus
lourde
la perpétuité avec une période de sûreté
de 22 ans
compte-rendu dominique verdeilhan
jean-marc nook
le visage est tendue les inquiète la
compagne d'yvan colonna viens d'entendre
les réquisitions même angoisse à peine
voilée chez le frère de l'accusé
perpétuité requise avec une période de
sûreté de 22 ans
l'avocat général ne crois pas aux
rétractations des membres du commando
vous avez vu avec quelle spontanéité ils
disent qu yvan colonna n'était pas sur
les lieux du crime une intime conviction
que partage la partie civile s'est
trouvé ce réquisitoire très complet a
relevé des charges très bien fait
absolument
membre du comité de soutien à yvan
colonna eric cantona assiste aux
plaidoiries de la défense
une défense qui reprochait à
l'accusation d'écarter tous les éléments
à décharge
sur le cac pertinent de la démonstration
je suis habité extrêmement réservés
on n'a rien écouté
et s'est contenté de
de réaffirmer ce que soient ses
convictions recul premier jour
perpétuité ou acquittement à la veille
du verdict il ne semble pas y avoir
d'autre alternative
la défense elle a choisi son combat ne
fait pas dit elle à la cour d'assises
divan colonna un dreyfus corse a quitté
le le verdict est attendu demain soir ou
dans la nuit
on revient maintenant sur la mort d'un
jeune homme de 24 ans et s'appelait
jordan il s'est jeté du 6e étage de son
immeuble à meylan dans l'isère et si
cette histoire retient l'attention c'est
parce qu'il était complètement enfermé
dans le monde des jeux vidéo sa mère a
décidé de témoigner pour attirer
l'attention sur ce qu'on appelle les no
life
ces adolescents où ces jeunes adultes
fasciné par ce monde virtuel au point
d'en devenir prisonnier et de perdre
pied parfois dans la vie réelle c'est le
dossier de cette édition
il est signé hakim abdel khaleq et m'a
dit diawara à 24 ans jordan s'est
suicidé en se jetant par la fenêtre
selon ses proches s'ils avaient perdu
tout contact avec le monde réel
enfermé dans sa chambre il jouait au jeu
vidéo plus de quinze heures par jour je
savais qu'il était vivant et qu'il était
là quand je l'entendais les faire
pupilles mais je veux dire à part ça si
on n'allait pas voir où ils étaient où
on aurait pu rester des jours sans voir
des copains on les voyait plus et avait
même plus au téléphone on choisir il se
désocialise il voyait plus personne un
jour internet tombe en panne jordan est
alors en manque une vraie crise il a
tourné comme une bête en cage il a fait
tous les voisins pour savoir où vous
pouvez brancher il était fou sans
basculer dans une situation aussi
extrême ces jeux en réseau sur internet
peuvent s'avérer dangereux benoît
pendant près de deux ans a été super
dépendants
il passe alors des jours entiers à
évoluer dans un monde virtuel qui
l'obsède
ce jeu est tellement absorbante gens
venaient à ne plus aller au lycée pour
jouer j'ai redoublé parce que là bas je
moi j'avais ce jeu me prenait tellement
que je comme je revenais le soir je me
faisais je me mettais directement sur ce
jeu je ne travaille pas ne faisait pas
mes devoirs je ne résidait pas mais le
son dans ce jeu qui n'a pas de fin
benoît tient le rôle d'un elle dotée de
pouvoirs surnaturels
il combat des monstres avec sa guilde
dans des quêtes éprouvante un personnage
dont il n'arrive plus à se défaire dans
mes rêves j'ai été le héros surpuissant
de mon jeu on a vraiment envie de
changer le monde est très puissant de
lutter contre les injustices qui nous
arrive de lutter même contre son
apparence son corps des choses qu'on
rejette finalement et le jeu nous offre
ce si cette évasion
chaque soir ses parents tentent
d'éteindre l'ordinateur mais ils
subissent les insultes et parfois même
les coûts de benoît toujours enfermé
dans son monde virtuel fond je coupe le
moteur
j'avais l'impression d'avoir une
créature face de moi j'étais une
créature pour lui pour 7 des instants
qui suivent est le moment où je coupais
totalement la connexion vous aviez
l'impression que c'était un personnage
du jeu
oui tout à fait et moi qui aie qui me
voyez moi comme une créature abattre un
ennemi à terrasser depuis quelques mois
benoît suit une thérapie
il va beaucoup mieux mais reste fragile
il lui arrive encore de passer une nuit
blanche devant son écran en france sur
500 mille adeptes des jeux en réseau
plus de dix mille jeunes de 18 à 30 ans
serait cyberdépendance
économie maintes fois entamés jamais
abouti c'est un immense chantier qui a
été rouvert aujourd'hui par le président
de la république et le gouvernement
celui de la réforme de l'état
objectif dépenser moins et tenter d'être
plus efficace une centaine de mesures
ont été présentées
cette fois ci ce rappel la bo sera
t-elle la bonne explication alexandre
kara frédéric de la rue voici la réforme
de l'état version 2007 avec un objectif
avoué faire des économies les
administrations publiques dépense chaque
année plus de 1000 milliards d'euros si
le taux de dépenses publiques dans la
richesse nationale et est le même qu'en
allemagne nous dépenserions 850
milliards d'euros premier chantier la
simplification administrative exemple la
délivrance des papiers d'identité sera
désormais confiée aux mairies dans le
même temps les horaires de l'accueil du
public dans les administrations seront
élargis petite révolution
les préfets de département seront à
l'avenir placé sous la tutelle des
préfets de région pour mieux piloter la
politique de l'état
tous les ministères vont devoir se
serrer la ceinture illustration à paris
avec la création d'un pentagone à la
française un super ministère de la
défense qui regroupera les états majors
des trois armées disséminés dans la
capitale
un nouveau bâtiment sera construit dans
le 15e arrondissement de paris financé
par la vente de biens immobiliers
les premières analyses financières que
nous faisons montre que l'opération est
très largement finançables sans que aso
aux contribuables au menu des économies
il ya bien sûr les fonctionnaires
en 2006 les quelques cinq millions de
fonctionnaires représentaient 44 % du
budget de l'état pour réduire la voilure
en 2008
un départ à la retraite sur trois ne
sera pas remplacé en 2009
accélération ce sera un sur deux au
total 97 mesure en attendant la deuxième
vague de réformes prévues au printemps
2008 alors question comment faire il
faut savoir que plusieurs pays européens
ont déjà procédé à cette réforme c'est
le cas par exemple de la suède
là bas le nombre de fonctionnaires a été
divisé par deux en dix ans avec quelles
méthodes et quels résultats envoyés
spéciaux à stockholm
il a mathias second au royaume de suède
si vous chercher aujourd'hui un bureau
de poste inutile d'arpenter les rues
c'est plutôt ici que vous le trouverez
dans ce centre commercial
on vient y faire ses courses mais aussi
envoyer son courrier et au guichet le
fostier n'est pas un fonctionnaire
mais un salarié du supermarché et des
bureaux de poste comme le sien gérées
par le secteur privé
il en existe cinq mille à travers le
pays j'aimais beaucoup aux anciens
bureaux tout une classique mais
maintenant nous disposons de cela et
c'est vrai je suis très satisfait de
leur chasse voilà à quoi ressemblaient
les bureaux traditionnels en dix ans sur
1800 près des trois quarts ont été
fermées les fonctionnaires qui
travaillaient pour la plupart embauché
par les postes privés les délais sont
améliorées 95% des courriers arrivent
aujourd'hui dans les 24 heures les
fonctionnaires eux ne gère plus que la
distribution à cause de la compétition
avec le secteur privé et l'arrivée des
nouvelles technologies
la substitution de l'e-mail on a dû tout
changer très rapidement et encore
aujourd'hui c'est dur de travailler à la
poste suédoise gare de stockholm un
train en provenance du nord comme pour
toutes les grandes lignes il est
exploité par la compagnie nationale
publique
les liaisons régionales sont gérés par
des compagnies privées elles ont recruté
les trois mille cinq cents agents
licenciés les 4000 qui sont restés
occupent les postes clés
nous n'avons conservé que les effectifs
dont nous avions besoin pour le trafic
que nous gérons il n'y a pas eu de
baisse de qualité à bord des trains se
sont en nombre les mêmes effectifs les
mêmes équipes que par le passé et nous
avons planifié les liaisons plus
efficace à faible taux de retard
d'incidents techniques la qualité de
service a été maintenue mais à un coût
sur certaines lignes
les tarifs ont quasiment doublé
et pourtant la majorité des suédois ne
s'en plaint pas et plébiscitent même à
travers les sondages la réforme
aujourd'hui la suède compte 220 mille
fonctionnaires contre 440 milles il ya
dix ans quatre fois moins que la france
à population comparable
et ce chantier de la réforme
administrative pourrait déboucher en
france sur une réforme du divorce
le gouvernement s'apprête en effet à
supprimer le recours au juge pour les
séparation par consentement mutuel
seul un passage devant le notaire serait
nécessaire officiellement il s'agit de
désengorger les tribunaux
l'idée renvoie aussi évidemment à la
banalisation du divorce nicolas
lemarignier jacques gérard du nouveau
dans le code civil bientôt peut-être le
gouvernement voudrait simplifier le
divorce par consentement mutuel
plus besoin pour les époux de passer
devant le juge accompagnés chacun d'un
avocat
une visite chez le notaire suffirait de
notaire qui déjà s'occupe du partage des
biens en cas de divorce
il s'agit d'aller au delà de ce que nous
faisons actuellement pour constater
l'accord des parties sur le divorce dès
lors qu'il n'ya aucun contentieux entre
eux chaque année la mesure concernerait
environ 5000 couple sur 75 mille cas de
divorce par consentement mutuel
c'est peu mais symbolique de l'évolution
vers plus de simplicité plus de rapidité
début des années 70 voilà comment il
faut faire alors pour divorcer entre
époux consentants cas sonder les
formalités à remplir pour les divorcés
le plus rapidement que sont les d'accord
de se séparer à l'amiable
si vous êtes d'accord pour divorcer en
fait il faudra une mise en scène pour le
tribunal en juillet 1975 la loi instaure
le consentement mutuel
on compte alors 55000 divorce par an
aujourd'hui c'est 150 mille procédure
annuel dont la moitié d'un commun accord
mais consentement mutuel ça ne veut pas
forcément dire séparation équitable
c'est pour cela que les avocats sont
opposés à la procédure devant le notaire
dire les gens vont se mettre d'accord
les chaînes docteur savent être
entérinée c'est très simple c'est
entériné en fait des situations de
déséquilibre au profit de celui qui
restera le client du notaire par exemple
au profit de celui qu'elle patrimoine on
ne se rend pas compte des conséquences
qui peuvent être dramatiques pour les
familles et pour les enfants
si on va dans cette voie les avocats
sont également en colère parce que la
réforme c'est du travail et des revenus
en moins pour eux le but de la mesure
c'est aussi de désengorger les tribunaux
et devant ce mécontentement des avocats
la garde des sceaux rachida dati
relativise il s'agit d'une piste de
travail qui doit encore être discutée at
elle indiqué tout à l'heure chez nos
confrères de france 24
le conseil des ministres a adopté
aujourd'hui le projet de loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat
rappelons d'abord les quatre mesures
principales il vise à inciter les
entreprises à convertir les rtt en
rémunération a autorisé le déblocage
anticipé de la participation et
lorsqu'elle n'existe pas à encourager
les pme à verser une prime
exceptionnelle
enfin l' indice de référence des loyers
sera désormais fondée sur l'évolution
des prix à la consommation et la caution
ramené de deux à un mois de loyer
à cette occasion nous avons voulu savoir
si comme on l'entend parfois les prix
sont plus élevés en france que chez nos
voisins européens
ça n'est pas une enquête exhaustive mais
un petit test menés sur quatre produits
en france en italie et en allemagne
reportage david boeri eric de l'agneau
avec nos bureaux de rome et de berlin
faire ses courses à paris à berlin et à
rome pour comparer les prix de 4
produits de grande consommation
premier produit dans notre caddie le
paquet de 500 grammes de spaghettis nous
avons retrouvé la même marque dans les
trois magasins bien sûr c'est à rome que
le rayon est le plus impressionnant
c'est là aussi quels sont les moins
chères car elles sont vendues un euro
0,9 en allemagne 93 centimes en france
et seulement 62 centimes en italie 2ème
rayons pour un litre de lait frais demi
écrémé des marques différentes dans
chaque pays avec là aussi d'importantes
différences de prix mais cette fois
c'est en allemagne que nous avons
trouvez le litre le moins cher seulement
66 centimes contre 1 euros 25 à paris et
jusqu'à 1 euro 50 à rome 3e produits le
dvd du dernier james bond à paris nous
l'avons trouvé en promotion à berlin à
un prix défiant toute concurrence 9
euros 90 contre 14 euros 99 en france
alors qu à rome il était vendu 16 euros
90 pour finir la course restait le litre
de super sans plomb 95 là c'est bien en
france que nous l'avons acheté le plus
cher un neuro 27 à berlin contre 1 euros
39 à paris et 1 euros 35 à rome les
résultats de notre petite addition pour
notre mini qu'a dit la capitale
allemande est la moins chère avec un
total de 12 euros 92 suivi de notre
capital 18 euros 56 la capitale
italienne
elle est au dessus des 20 euros selon
les études officielles de l' ocde
ces trois pays sont très proches mais
les prix en moyenne sont quand même
légèrement plus élevés en france les
taxes sont relativement élevés donc ça
monte le bruit des produits mais ces
taxes servent à financer l'éducation la
santé qui elle est pratiquement gratuit
pour le consommateur alors que dans
d'autres pays par exemple pour
l'allemagne
l'éducation coûte plus cher faute
d'harmonisation fiscale on est donc
encore très loin des primes uniques en
europe en bref on évoquer l italie et
bien c'est le soulagement
les trois principaux syndicats de
chauffeurs routiers en grève depuis
lundi suspendre leur blocus qui vous le
voyez avait de grandes conséquences le
gouvernement a fait des propositions sur
l'emploi et le prix des carburants
depuis avant-hier les autoroutes étaient
complètement bloquées et des premiers
signes de pénurie se sont fait sentir
dans les rayons des magasins
soulagement aussi à la frontière franco
italienne à vintimille ou 2000 camions
étaient tout de même bloqué ces derniers
jours à propos de transport on a appris
que les services de police
antiterroriste ont été saisis car une
série d'explosions ont été constatés
contre des radars automatiques
jusque là des dégradations avaient été
parfois constaté cette fois une nouvelle
étape est franchie une bombe artisanale
vient encore d'être découverte
arnaud compte michael cariou
la bombe a été découverte au pied de ce
radar hier matin vers 9h30 par le
personnel chargé du nettoyage de la
chaussée
l'engin artisanal repérer à temps n'a
pas explosé vous aviez un pont
une sorte de
de pelote de cils avec un boîtier la
minuterie sur le dessus un pont ici et
quelque chose d'autre derrière que j'ai
pas vu cette bombe aurait pu faire
d'importants dégâts l'affairé est prise
très au sérieux les spécialistes de la
sous direction antiterroriste de la
police judiciaire sont chargés de
l'enquète elles concernent sept dossiers
d'attentats réussis ou ratés depuis
avril dernier
à chaque fois la cible est un radar
automatique de la région parisienne et
la banque conçu presque toujours de la
même manière un explosif capable de
projeter les débris du boîtier à plus de
20 mètres un seul de ces attentats a été
revendiqués par une mystérieuse
organisation
pour l'heure les enquêteurs ignorent
s'ils ont affaire à un groupe organisé
ou à des actes de vandalisme isolés ils
ont décidé de placer discrètement sous
vidéosurveillance les radars les plus
efficaces en bref encore à propos de
transport les enquêteurs canadiens ont
rendu leurs conclusions sur le crash de
l'airbus a340 survenu en 2005 à toronto
on en avait beaucoup parlé l'avion était
sorti de la piste mais sans faire de
mort comme souvent plusieurs facteurs
sont en cause le mauvais temps une
vitesse excessive et une omission de
l'équipage qui avait mal calculé
semble-t-il la distance requise pour se
poser un spot pour ingrid betancourt
france télévisions a décidé de
s'associer aux familles pour diffuser ce
petit film de 30 secondes vous le
découvrirez sur toutes les chaînes du
groupe
une pétition est également disponible
sur internet voici ce film y est la fac
ou question m'a mise chez honda on est
rassuré la messe normal c'est qu'on est
tous
non mais c'est quoi ce truc
voilà d'autres informations aussi sur
france 2 point fr l'environnement avec
comme chaque jour des nouvelles du
sommet de bali sur les mesures à prendre
face aux changements climatiques journée
marquée par la ratification officielle
du protocole de kyoto par l'australie le
premier brahms et calvin rude
récemment élu a remis les documents et
s'est fait applaudir à la tribune il
s'agit du 37e membres de ce club entre
guillemets voici maintenant l'une des
dix villes les plus polluées au monde ce
n'est pas une formule ce triste
classement a été établi par une
fondation d'experts britanniques
il s'agit de la ville de jeans qu en
russie en 1930 elle est devenue la
capitale chimiques de l'urss
des millions de mètres cubes de déchets
ont été enfouis sans protection ni
surveillance et rien n'a été fait depuis
pour dépolluer reportage sur ce site
interdit qui n'avait jamais été filmées
laurent bouvier xavier luizet à la
surface des centaines de fûts rouillé
jeté là depuis des dizaines d'années
chlore plomb phénol dioxines des
produits hautement toxiques déchets des
anciennes usines d'armement chimie de la
région abandonnée à ciel ouvert sans
aucun traitement
un silence oppressant partout une odeur
lourdes acres presque
pourtant le pire n'est peut-être pas la
catin pendant vingt ans avec 70 des
milliers de tonnes de déchets dangereux
aujourd'hui ils sont très mauvais état
les déchets peuvent rejaillir à tout
moment et la pollution s'étendre partout
construite à partir de 1930 jeans qu'à
400 km de moscou a été jusqu'à la fin de
la guerre froide la capitale chimiques
de l'urss ville interdite
c'est à dire où aucun étranger n'avait
le droit de pénétrer ces usines ont
déversé sans contrôle pendant 60 ans des
millions de tonnes de déchets dans la
nature pour dimitri militants
écologistes
les sols sont pollués sur huit à vingt
mètres de profondeur au procès se
polluer silva gueule vers la rivière
locale traverse la troisième ville de
russie et surtout pollue les eaux
souterraines qui alimenterait population
locale kgo attention danger
ouverte en 1939 cette usine a produit
pendant trente ans de l'ypérite utilisés
dans les gaz de combat à certains
endroits le niveau de pollution et 17
millions de fois supérieur aux normes
sanitaires
conséquence dans les cimetières de la
région on peut voir un nombre
impressionnant de tombes de personnes
décédées avant d'avoir quarante et un
ans il est mort à 36 ans il ya beaucoup
de jeunes ici la plupart d'entre nous
avons des mots de tests mal aux jambes à
les habitants d'origine son père meurt
dans le dira à dire gince que 300000
habitants le taux de mortalité est
évidemment supérieure à la moyenne haute
et pourtant les choses changent
la faillite de l'industrie soviétique au
début des années 90 et la fermeture
d'une grande partie des usines de la
région ont entraîné une amélioration de
la qualité de l'air mais rien n'est fait
pour dépolluer les sols ni pour stopper
le ruissellement des eaux saturé de
produits chimiques
quelques initiatives dérisoire au regard
de l'ampleur de la catastrophe
écologique en cours ont été prises pour
essayer d'améliorer les choses mais rien
de systématique rien d'important et on
peut donc raisonnablement penser que
dire jeans restera encore pendant de
nombreuses années la ville la plus
polluée chimiquement du monde toujours
en russie garry kasparov renonce il
indique qu'il ne sera finalement pas
candidat à l'élection présidentielle de
mars prochain
trop d'embûches trop de pression pour
pouvoir faire réellement campagne dit-il
les sciences vivre sur la lune ce n'est
pas seulement un rêve c'est aussi un
projet qui a été confirmé par la nasa
une date est même fixée pour une
première station 2020 et les ingénieurs
parle déjà de bâtir une ville sur la
lune
nicolas chateauneuf jacques gérard
il y à 35 ans l'équipage d'apollo 17
faisait de la jeep à la surface de la
lune depuis la poussière grise est resté
immobile mais cela pourrait changer car
la nasa un grand projet celui de
construire une base permanente sur la
lune d'ici à 2020
un avant poste qui pourrait dans un
premier temps accueillir un équipage de
huit personnes maximum
l'emplacement le pôle sud choisie pour
sa richesse en ressources minières un
coût en carburant moins élevés et un
ensoleillement quasi permanent mais pour
cela il faut tout réinventer de
nouvelles fusées de nouveaux modules
lunaires plus puissants capables déposé
à la surface les différents éléments de
la base
ce moyen de transport en mode
automatique va poser les unités
d'habitation les véhicules pour se
mouvoir sur la lune les unités de
d'énergie pour avoir de l'énergie
électrique avec des panneaux solaires
donc il y aura toute une activité de
construction avec des allers retours de
deux cargos déposer un nouvel équipage
sur la lune ne sera pas le plus
difficile
le principal défi c'est de fournir assez
d'énergie de nourriture d'eau et
d'oxygène aux membres de cette base
permanente pour rendre cela possible
il faudra inventer de nouvelles
technologies mais les scientifiques
espèrent bien les mettre à profit pour
un projet bien plus ambitieux encore la
conquête de mars
on en vient à ce qu'il faut bien appeler
un pavé dans la mare regardez la une du
prestigieux magazine américain time qui
annonce tout simplement la mort de la
culture française et met au défi ses
lecteurs ne citer un artiste vivant ou
un écrivain français d'envergure
mondiale alors faut-il effectivement
parlé d'un déclin français
voici l'état des lieux les arguments des
uns et des autres chacun se fera son
idée le débat avec daniel wolfromm et
jean-marie lequertier la môme troisième
plus grosse entrée de l'histoire du
cinéma français aux états unis à tabac
est tout un symbole unis veulent des
années 50 quand la culture française
dominait encore
tiens saint-germain-des-prés ses cafés
de jean paul sartre
le maître à penser à michel foucault le
philosophe des années 70 oui mais deux
générations plus tard patatras
et aujourd'hui d'après le magazine time
notre culture serait déjà morte une
poignée seulement de nos romans sont
traduits aux états unis alors qu'un
tiers des livres traduits ici sont anglo
saxons bref la culture française
d'année en année s'étiole
je trouve le constat de cet article de
time sur le déclin à ses justes et je ne
discuterai pas parce que on est enfant
petit village gaulois un peu culturel
qui essaye de se défendre alors qu' il
est vrai qu'on a une culture qui est
assez élitiste je constate pas soulevé
depuis les années 50 avec l'un
particulier au contraire depuis dix ans
je vois apparaître de nouveaux noms à
côté des grands des grands noms qui sont
comme par les grandes collections
américaines soit christophe qui savent
crise important si sophie calle daniel
buren ou annette messager et d'autres
d'ailleurs
oui mais tout le problème est là
si cette année le peintre le mieux vendu
au monde jean michel basquiat est un
américain le premier artiste français
robert combas n'apparaît lui qu'à la
108e place
la comparaison avec les salles de ventes
internationales est encore plus
édifiante la place de paris et dix à
vingt fois moins importante que ses
grandes rivales chinoises ou anglo saxon
et le vieux débat de refaire surface en
france trop de régulation pas assez de
marché
on a une culture je dirais très
centralisé extrêmement définies par les
pouvoirs publics avec une sorte de
mystère la culture qui est un peu je
veux diriger définir cette culture si
elle pas l'état y aura pas la collection
du centre pompidou qui est de la
deuxième collection au monde qui est
parmi les 2,3 grande collection au monde
d'art moderne et d'art contemporain pour
enfoncer le clou times juge le cinéma
français confidentiel nombriliste à
faible budget faut jamais les films
français ne se sont mieux vendus en
amérique que cette année la môme ou la
marche de l'empereur de vrai succès
preuve s'il en est qu'en matière
culturelle
il faut bien se démarquer et faire
preuve d'originalité en bref le prix et
louis delluc 2007 a été décerné au film
la graine et le mulet d'abdellatif
kechiche déjà récompensé trois fois au
festival de venise
football une gifle pour marseille en
ligue des champions hier soir l'om a été
surclassé il n'y a pas d'autre mot par
liverpool 4 à 0 au stade de vélodrome
donc et devra se contenter de la coupe
de l'uefa
voici les bus anglais quelques-uns début
et puis une image de parachute urbain
avec le défi de cet autrichien qui s'est
élancé de la tour la plus haute du monde
508 mètres à taipei il avait caché à son
matériel
car ce genre de show est bien sûr
totalement interdit la réussit aussi à
échapper à la police
à son arrivée sur les trottoirs
n'essayez pas de faire la même chose
avant de refermer cette édition je vous
en rappelle deux des principaux titres
l'algérie en deuil
al qaïda au maghreb a revendiqué le
double attentat bière qui a fait 72
morts selon la presse on a appris que
l'un des kamikazes étaient âgés de 55
ans et puis la prison à perpétuité avec
une période de sûreté de 22 ans c'est la
peine maximale requise contre yvan
colonna devant la cour d'assises de
paris
verdict sans doute demain soir c'est la
fin de ce journal merci à vous de
m'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
nathalie rihouet 20h50 un téléfilm la
vie à mains nues à demain
l'info en continu on s'est aussi sur
france 2 point fr